get going and
and as we get ready for this third and
final playoff
uh once again it's sim situation
finals
yeah the jinx is coming but okay
all right everyone needs to do is win
levon wins we go to two armageddons i i
enjoy this yeah let's go for yeah let's
oh whoa
what is this
this exists
it will be to arm against if levon wins
but if mvl manages to hold off levon
that will give him tournament victory
this is incredible
and we have some kind of random sicilian
as the choice of lebanon c4
they don't want to test mvl in the main
line of the poison pawn either
no
kind of understandably so
quite a fair here to begin things there
we go thank you
just happy
h6
you know what what i mean
is he is he going to play g5 what in a
monster
h6 a novelty that's funny
oh oh i've got something good yeah it's
like it's just an actual novelty well
i'm not surprised
a4 played and
what
earth is the point of this move h6
it can't be that
bad but
what is it preventing
i have no idea what this is about like
zero zero clue why six is funny actually
zero clue why we spend the tempo on this
like no idea whatsoever
wow i understand h3 h6
yeah i think it's aimed against h3
because he is he's winning he's waiting
to pounce right he he h3g5 h3 g5 yeah oh
wait and you've got to go way you play
h3g5 in this tournament situation and
honestly
i think i think if i were lev here i
would very seriously considering playing
h3 which i think is a bad move just
because it promotes g5
and look at what he did for vogue by the
way he did provoke bishop to g4 h3
and if you thought you didn't understand
why he played h6 now you know it's
bishop
correct it's just to save the bible
that's right knight h4 i mean the max
team actually spent the time to analyze
the bishop c4 sicilian because nothing
nothing would shock me anymore like
we're we're done with the shocks yeah
yeah yeah knight f2 let's go
yeah
but this is like the perfect position
for levon considering the tournament
situation i'm i'm very much doubting
he's doing well
but who cares but no he's got the kind
of chaotic position that he is it's
absolutely relevant what the evaluation
here is because you know 32 pieces on
the board and like a huge big mess
there's only one also a result that
counts for him also i'm not sure he's
doing so poorly because like i really
really just like but maybe that's fine
honestly i am honestly surprised at how
poorly the engine thinks of this
position for the one
really yeah
but you you can't stop the 65 and then
things start kind of spreading spreading
out well how bad is it so i take yeah
yeah we just castle into it i have no
problems casting and do it here yeah
i'll keep developing yeah bishop d6 or
whatever i certainly see
castling into it being fine you could
start with queen d6 too right yeah yeah
but even even this like i i don't i
don't really see why we're doing so
poorly i'm not saying poorly i wouldn't
wait for white or black
i mean i was being you know polite
to
by the way
that doesn't work around uh alejandro
and i i mean yeah being polite my other
milders and betters yeah
that's not
no that's not the way we roll we're
headed that way yeah all the way to
bishop has already been played onto the
board yeah mvl castles without a
moment's hesitation 26 was playable but
yeah could you actually maybe the idea
of castling queen sign right yeah
exactly question queen said g6
wow so it was actually maybe a much more
critical choice i don't know if critical
because this is also about muscles yeah
wow okay
hasn't been played yet
excuse me
that was our analysis yeah uh queen f3
944 between g2
yeah but i don't think g5 ever really
hangs in those types of locations
knight f3 uh
bringing
seven
in
well okay i got it i gotta cover g3 what
can i say and then rook again yeah the
bishop one h7 looks silly but the white
setup in general just like okay how
about knight e2 and no 92 you're going
to play bishop f4 i get that there's
like something to be said about knight
before at some point
right
okay yeah it's just very comfortable for
black and uh
i keep on trying trying to find a way to
revive the bishop on h7 immediately but
we don't we just don't need to we don't
have to yeah we can play without for a
while
well the big the big issue right now is
we've got to stop queen g3 which he does
yeah king g2 uh rook d8
defending the pawn on d5 it's such a
logical move rook did c4 is so much
stronger bishop you played once again
kind of in in full expectation of having
to deal with the potential opening of
the g-file eventually so you play bishop
too but yeah what your next goodies are
yeah so it's all it's all been played
it's all been played the bishop night
before
tonight i guess
with much regret if you want to keep the
bishop you put it on b1 and there's no
choice he does it immediately because he
knows there's no choice yeah at what
point
how much do i have to prepare bishop
takes that five knight h5 quite a bit
right
yeah 92 exists so yeah quite a bit uh
i'm thinking that from white's
perspective he's got to play knight e2
and c3 as soon as possible to liberate
him
by uh by mvl yeah to liberate his uh
position this is just very very
comfortable for black
h6 eh h6 is the new way to play the
sicilian how are you hersh
who knew
because
the strong bishop on h7 yes yes yes
again i'm thinking 92 you you play it
quickly
you know your position is right
yeah i don't even have to react i think
the bishop takes before ideas i'm pretty
sure i'm
i don't think i was ever really
intending
then i drop it back to c6 and yeah i'm
just really really not sure what white
ever wants in this position i love your
rook
[Music]
itself right
yeah
put your rook on that open file
yeah i keep on looking at some
tactics
knows those principles no tactics
involved here goes rook fe-8
exactly
okay well even so i got to do something
c3
knight c6 knight e2 to g1
trying to get some
some
squares and
play for my pieces the rook on a1 the
queen on d1 particularly pathetic at the
moment yeah
yeah you have to somehow crawl out of
this corner and uh
if you play c3 if you play c3 and bishop
c2 i'm wondering if c5 c4 is also an
idea but i'm not sure i need to give the
d4 square to okay so the white pieces i
wanted to secure the e4 square for the
knight on f6 i understood i understood
but i'm not a hundred percent convinced
that that it's necessary to even give
you yeah i mean we can play slower
the problem that i'm seeing also is that
if i play c3 knight c6 and
i'm you might even have h5 eventually
eventually h5 will become playable yeah
yeah i'm seeing a lot of opportunity
what did he do he took him before but i
think that was that's a
poof that's a big oof yeah yeah and he
wanted to play two back trying to at
least you know
b3 and uh yeah but he's eyeballing like
in a kind of a perfect world you just
get mated on the dark squares here this
is where h5 terrifies me g5 and and
[Music]
maybe even something like knight e4
might work in some positions but
why yeah why because why why bother yeah
why bother
there has to be actually like g7 g6 is
now i think very very playable yeah g6
is what liberator has told us but bishop
c5 i like yeah bishop z5 rookie 3 you
don't really want to play d4 ever g6
played g6 by mvl on point on target
opening the position for his bishop
finally yeah maybe queen g2 but i guess
we could have like bishop c5 and
three right i mean that's
that's that's a very uninvited guest on
the e3 square but g7 g6 yeah starts
liberating yeah starting to dig out the
bishop on h7 that makes perfect sense
and white's position like this king on
g2 without the dark square bishop to
cover it it's just yeah the moment the
moment one bad thing happens to the
right position probably is the first and
the last
it's missing the dark trade bishop it's
also missing the light squared bishop
it's not gonna get back to the defense
can i uh suggest queen d2 yeah well my
point was even if the best move i have
is king g7 i'm still kind of fine making
it
i was hoping that i was going to
scare you i'm not very scared about that
song it's tricky to work
okay
is interesting knight h5 is kind of a
move that i would like to make maybe
[Laughter]
repulsive
that is repulsive rookie two bishop f4
oh my gosh talk about being on the back
foot there oh
uh yeah nope uh
yeah
six played yeah though this is just on
g6 and bishop takes
position for white was was played and
the bishop is digging itself out of a
hole and quinjitsu
honestly like i already started thinking
that maybe 94 kind of wins in some of
these positions but there's absolutely
no reason to hurry with it exactly you
just play king g7 you you don't have to
do anything spectacular you're just
better
i'm kind of you know
i'm a little partial to king h7 only
because you're king white's king is on
the g file and maybe on a good day
something could happen on the g file
partnership stop defending h5 let's go
yeah h5 g594 right something something
along those lines
yeah and this is better than
my original suggestion simply because oh
there it is 94 on the board yeah he is
yeah he is enjoying himself
now
oh boy and then e3 before check and like
white is just oh that's getting
destroyed completely getting completely
destroyed yeah well he's playing pieces
down yeah a number of pieces down if you
don't take on e4 you're kind of
completely lost so you you kind of close
your eyes and go you take c4 like
and for envia what a turn of fortune
when you think about
what he was suffering a moment ago
against wesley and wesley had it all
under control now he's a man
in control of his own destiny and
winning with the black pieces just looks
completely winning i think it's just
done yeah yeah wow you don't even
particularly need to calculate it just
looks like look at that
he goes yeah i mean
and he just dropped back with his queen
one you go once you go quinty one you
you kind of know the game is up
i assume there is some kind of i mean g3
probably wins on the sport or something
yeah
there's no immediate immediate wins but
pretty much every move keeps
all the advantage all the advantages
maybe bishop f4 queen is seven i quite
like guys guys any movements
it's okay we just need to let maxine
choose one the position plays itself out
every move that black makes that creates
a threat is difficult to answer even a
move like queen c5 is difficult to
answer hmm
yeah it's it it looks horrendous and
you know the shocking part about this
position is that this is actually equal
material we haven't sacrificed anything
yet yeah
anything to get right here yeah we're
doing this for free yeah yeah exactly we
sure are we're doing this for free with
black yeah
i'm guessing rook fan is the only move
dropping in
uh threatening potentially knight f2
yeah that was my initial impression but
i i struggled to find any kind of a
killing blow after rook of one so i went
back on it
but i guess white steel has no threat so
we can go i don't know h5 h4 here right
now like just like cemented there at
some point you just take on e4 i hope
for the best though and we do
i like h5 h4 a lot i like bishop f4 a
lot
yeah
maybe not the cleanest but should still
be just to be very strong right
yeah
uh as uh yeah played you yes alejandra
says he's got his choice of wins
unfortunately for us
i think
you have to close your eyes take on e4
right pray that you don't get mad
absolutely because what what move do you
have in this position well do b3
if you're going to suffer you might as
well uh suffer on a full tummy take the
night take the night close your eyes
uh
yes i'm lost yes i know
but yeah it's it's exactly it's exactly
that kind of a situation yeah
even without the tournament situation
too taken to take into account you just
can't make yeah exactly like you just
you just do it and by the way the good
news about it
you know what that bishop on a2 is now
finally finally alive yeah unfortunately
for you you probably get mater than the
game
somehow give me one turn all i need is
rook f6 and queen f1 and i'm i'm back in
with a shout out yeah a strong shot how
is how is the like queen e5 takes g5
looks kind of good but i don't want to
give you time to play i don't know king
h1 and then maybe g1 queen f1 or
something actually rookie 5 is the only
move the engines think is completely
winning everything else is still
playable for both sides rook e5 you know
i think e5 take on g5 also is very very
it's very logical but yeah i also feel
that this isn't as clean optically
as the lines without
h4 and bishop gt3 bishop g3 felt a bit
like you were getting a bit sidetracked
right yeah come on he was cementing his
bishop over there next to white's king i
you can't begrudge him
that
rookie five
is uh it's a nice follow-up to the whole
um
adventure yeah again
with with
with bishop g3 it's a it's a reasonable
moment i think he clock times uh four
minutes against five and a half four
minutes for that one
four minutes against five and a half
well
do i dare i say it it's crunch time
oh
my
i think we're going to have to put a
maximum on the amount of hours per
product yeah exactly exactly it's done
it's like
it's like
like like the uh the pilot it was the
pilots you know it can only be yeah
aboard ship for so long yeah it was the
the very cheerful yaki
that did it for me like i i thought i
lost you on that one boom boom rookie
five by maxime takes his time but finds
the move i don't know why it's like so
crushing but you can kind of understand
yeah
but i thought i thought king h1 c3
couldn't queen g7 i think ends the game
there right because you can't protect
the palm h3o i was thinking about queen
d7 but 96 and i don't know ah okay you
make pretense
yeah okay
i understand yeah
look bad but yeah i'm surviving king
sort of surviving sort of surviving
i know i've seen rookie fight
yeah rookie five let's say we go c3 or
g5 king h1 here
and uh i thought q7 just ended the game
but there is knight e6
after which
black is obviously much better but the
game is somehow still a float right yeah
still flares anew as they say yeah yeah
and as we saw from the previous game
yeah it's not over anything can happen
yeah yeah
queen c8 may be stronger it might be
a slight issue yeah that might be a bit
of an issue yeah
knight g1 would you put it that way yeah
i understand that is that hey guys you
know like
we're all a little ropey over here uh
we're all a little bit look loopy
yeah oh boy oh boy um
on the other hand other suggestions do
not come easy i don't know like
can i actually kind of do want to play
queen g2 just to make it kind of make
the make it end please make it like when
it took me out misery yeah e3 queen
takes before rook takes g5 king h1
and i still have knight of three as a
response to the bush before check so i'm
not there to the most to the most
obvious move in the position i assume
i'm dead to something there i assume so
too yeah
i think oh no damn i thought i found
something very beautiful there to show
but what's wrong with rick g5 here we're
[ __ ] h1 and yeah this is the position
i was talking about like how do we put
the
yeah this is this unfortunately loses
the b6 check or it would have been a
better move oh
nasty nobody can go like who put my
queen on b4 i didn't put my clean up you
even took a palm did you okay
i'm attacking this bishop yes i don't
know this if this is great again the
clock times guys uh one and a half
minute four for lev uh
sitting solidly on five minutes oh he's
doing great on his clock as
lavonz is ticking down
um anything to be said for queen c1
queens he's gone rook f6 rook f6 yeah
you have to wonder what the replies rook
takes g5 is though against g6
although i don't know why you won my
bishop that doesn't improve anything he
just goes king h1 here well the
difference now is that any queen d7
moves he does at least
so
and there's 96 tactics
tacticos 96. this should be fine looks
pretty good
[Laughter]
one more look bishop e5 queen here yeah
take on g4 take on d4 and then you drop
with the queen no i mean here i just
take on default twice honestly well even
that yeah sorry sorry i just think you
thought
somehow in my mind i had a pawn on c3 i
don't know exactly how it got not yet
but rook f6 is going to be walking into
this
incredibly powerful bishop to d4 retreat
and that's johnny ball game yeah
it's johnny ball game indeed yeah sir
seems to be maybe the only clean
solution here but it's should be should
be very logical yeah there's there are
some pieces we can attack here with
tempe so why not attack them with
stamping well the engines think that b3
is also winning followed by
yeah white is also i mean black is also
at least supporting the knight on d4
yeah yeah giving him queen f1 in case of
queen d7 but yeah there has to be a way
to win this by force and at least he's
not forced to resign right you keep the
game going keep the game going you hope
your opponents understand that's what
it's all about that's about what the
fight is about here foreign he's doing a
good job he's done a good job throughout
the tournament not having to resign so
many positions where you're like okay
dude that's it resign yeah just yeah
goodbye could you please yeah could you
please
yeah
apparently apparently rook d6 rook of
six is the way to actually put it into
that no i'm going to be teasing lavon
for ages i mean it's going to be like
you know lavon or rhony and teaches you
chess and we're gonna have all of his
games forever from bucharest where he
was on the back foot and time and time
again he saved lost positions
yeah yeah mvl is so on point
by the way so on point
along with because you kind of do want
to stop queen f1 queen of one would
allow white a semblance of stabilization
there but now it always gets hit by rook
df6 and has no squares again has to go
backwards exactly i actually love that
that is a great it is such a such a nice
move and then when you put the rook on
f6 and you take on d4 and now can you do
something
on c3
yeah and at some point here that one
remembers he's playing for a win
no draw yeah no draws no draws
along with the ten thousand dollar
bonus for the winner
uh
the winner
will get 12 gct points
um yeah yeah for this first competition
not 13 yeah the one the one slight
dampener on on the proceedings 22 plate
but yeah you just go queen d7 i guess
right uh or dc like 27 forcing something
or not really forcing nigeria i thought
it was forcing knight g1 but there is
queen e3 which i assume loses through g3
but why bother
rogue gf6 is also of course completely
completely okay
absolutely the one finding a way to
continue though once again yeah right
three maybe the one way not to give up
straight away bishop takes d4 you're
gonna recapture i assume with the pawn
in order to keep the rook out of g3
and don't make me make moves i know i
mean yeah exactly exactly don't don't
make me make yeah
and he friends don't let friends play
friends don't let friends drive right
yes very nice yeah rook df6 rook g1
played by the one so he's actually
look at him he's like okay
i've got to do something and i've got to
do it fast
well
move good move by lavon
i mean rook takes knight takes and we're
still kicking up a fuss
very much so actually after
rookie 191 it's not even that easy is it
yeah
right yeah
apparently apparently rogue g3 is -8 but
only
you're your vision finally
yeah it's bishop jesus bishop okay yeah
okay yeah that makes that makes more
sense
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
he cheats in the best way possible yeah
nice
yeah 27 27 chosen by uh by mvl that's
it's pretty clean yeah queen
you got to take and go knight g1 that's
the only literally the only thing here
15 seconds for levon aronian and he has
captured there it goes yeah and nigerian
but the position remains
horrible uh kind of horrible yeah all
the end games are lost as well like if i
take on c3 and take on d4 here like all
all of those positions are also
completely lost exactly because yeah
having to defend the pawn on h3 has
played the move knight g1
yeah rg3 looks natural but uh
i'm just kind of like reeling from p4b3
it was like what
now you come on
we have had uh
i want to just say a big shout out to
the players we had a great deal of fun
analyzing your games and sharing our
views with our audience
uh i thought this was a great fighting
event
absolutely the number of decisive games
may not have been that high but boy they
were full of content and it was really a
great joy
to follow these games
and working with yourselves and
the good folks in romania bucharest that
was really fun too
so
thanks to everybody yeah down to 30
seconds and the game is still somehow
still going yeah i know the reason we're
still here is because this could still
turn around guys lavon somehow has
gotten and it's 20.
you'll soon be 15 and at that point you
start getting nervous exactly and
why he hasn't played rook g3 yet because
he's nervous
and it's ten seconds nine take on
defense do it just take on d4 and what
yeah that
takes a4 and accordingly
he's barely better
but he only needs a draw though so yeah
at some point
[Laughter]
he's doing it from a position of
strength
yeah he's clearly kind of uh let go of
much of his advantage but yeah yeah but
it's still yeah yeah you're not losing
doesn't mean
f4 i'm telling you guys queen f4 yeah
or something yeah
don't
[Music]
wow
and again three results possible bishop
takes b7 put it back on g2 and play yeah
yeah why not i don't even know why he
didn't take on b7 yeah if you're playing
bishop gt anyway why not just you know
snack snack on the b7 pawn as well yeah
wow
guys guys the game is flared
this is a new game this is a whole new
game yeah white has queen e4
i mean
h4 knight f5
and we could be into in for three two
armageddons like
knight h4
and it could be two armageddons coming
up uh
look at this
95 yeah
95 certainly it doesn't do much yeah and
the b pawn will start being a
destruction yeah deep deep is rolling uh
okay the deep one is rolling guys i'm
telling you d6 is the big threat i think
we in d6 right yeah
now i can reposition my knight knight d4
is a movement five as a move
the s6 rear craft stick
no rook f6 knight g3 threatening d6 yeah
rook of two but he goes knight three
anyway yeah knight three it's a whole
whole new thing yeah it's a whole new
world it's a whole new thing yeah 93
wow
guys this is live
i'm telling you i mean why is today
it's not friday the 13th but it could
have been i mean it feels like it was
my goodness
how to play chess
[Music]
king h2 yeah quincy two we can go quick
queen e4 if we need to and we kind of
need to we don't we can't trade queens
here
no
no we cannot but we have to defend g2
and we do have to
keep yeah this is a king of f8 is a very
very very good yeah because like the
five and allows queen for checking as we
mentioned yeah you can kind of push the
h pawn off king h i just played four
there but okay yeah i don't know
king h3
get the key out of john dodge
there's a threat right finally there is
a threat in every single something like
d6 perhaps but queen thanks to six
unfortunately okay threatening 97 yeah
alert alert right rookie two
seven is a threader
rookie two turkey two
four feelings quincy four let's go
oh still a game threatening mate is the
threat of mate where's the mate queen c8
is kind of i mean with nothing kind of a
made but it's not made so you can go b2
here but i don't know if he can go b2
i don't know if he could do it either
but what is chat runs yeah then it runs
i think he's still again again we're
running no yeah oh my god but there are
no more checks and black will have
checks
there quinty three one will win right
queen and he flagged he flagged oh i
wow
that is quite something yeah that that
whole that whole tie break from start to
finish was
quite something
[Laughter]
guys
that was uh
that was an adventure and a half i mean
wow maxine our winner and our great
congratulations and the suffering peter
that was there well
yeah uh
yeah
you know technically he won both games
on time but he was winning in both final
positions right
yeah that's that's not really how how it
ended but yeah
alejandro is standing there with this
kind of a glade
trying to process what we just watched
what did we just watch
what happened what happened today